gone ahead Avengers infinity war was and
is still a cultural phenomenon ten years
worth of movies in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe led to it and fans all over the
world were shocked by some of its brazen
story choices the long-awaited arrival
of Josh Brolin's Thanos surprisingly to
many lived up to the six year hype he
wasn't just a giant purple I mean blue I
mean pink skinned alien bad guy out to
destroy the universe just because he's
evil
he had layers you get it we both have
layers Daniels didn't want to destroy
the universe no no Fanus only wanted to
destroy half the universe well half the
population of the universe in his mind
he's the hero he wants to save who he
can from the same fate his own planet
underwent and he thinks this extreme
method is the only way to bring peace to
all living beings this nuanced take on
the character made for some emotional
scenes that almost had some of us
sympathizing with the antagonist because
when it comes down to it the best
villains don't think they're villains at
all our hero's desperate struggle to
meet unite and fight was often
compelling seeing star-lord interact
with Ironman tap meeting Groot Black
Panther sharing a scene with Bruce
Banner it's truly incredible how this
film contains so many characters and
they all for the most part had at least
a moment to shine we know them so well
at this point that only a couple minutes
of screen time seemed to stretch much
further there's no doubt about it
Avengers infinity war delivered on
surprises character growth a villain
with empathetic emotions and much more
but what if it was taken in a different
direction what if another highly
influential creative force with comic
book movie experience was at the helm of
Marvel's biggest film what if
[Music]
oh yeah now that's cool
that's right I'm back bitches and you're
gonna listen to what I have to say first
of all my boys at DC aren't killing it
you're like Wonder Woman you're welcome
you're like Aquaman you're welcome
you're like Justice League you're the
only one don't you worry the hashtag
Snider cut will find its way to your
eyeballs sooner than you think
that hack just sweetened compromised my
vision if my true masterpiece will come
to light just you wait and by the way
why does James Gunn think he can double
dip over to my universe news flash
guardians of the galaxy sucked part 2
sucked harder what a wasted Jeff Bridges
and now he's producing a Superman horror
film yeah I already see it buddy it's
called bane of Steve why don't you stop
ripping me off and go back to tweeting
about jerking off it is what you're best
at and that brings me to Marvel and
their stupid Mickey Mouse Cinematic
Universe everything's always sunshine
and rainbows Oh everything's always so
funny isn't it you all need to wake the
fuck up once you've lost your virginity
to my king boobies and then you come and
say to me something about like my
superheroes wouldn't do that I'm like
are you serious I'm like down the road
on that bro it's a cool point of view to
be like my heroes are still innocent
my heroes didn't lie to America by
heroes didn't embezzle money from their
corporations my heroes didn't commit any
atrocities that's cool but you're living
in a dream world man I haven't even
wasted my time watching your dumb
infinity war movie and I'm sick of
hearing about how much people like it so
I'm gonna fix your shit scene by sea
that's right it's time for Marvel let me
Schneider eyes let's get this going
okay first things first somebody turn
down the color on this thing it's like a
unicorn vomited on a rainbow thank God
now it could work
oh right away Upsy had problems why is
the fight with Hulk and Thanos so short
these two should be tearing it up for at
least 45 minutes and I don't know how
you guys feel about green but it's a
putrid color now grey that's a hue I
could do there we go
you should have looked like this in the
first place but something's still
missing he's just not cool enough ooh
spikes nice in fact perfect ladies and
gentlemen forget incredible I present to
you the superior Hulk
South and a bunch of aliens arrived on
earth and the spaceship from prometheus
and tear up downtown New York after a
little tussle with a bad guy some of the
heroes are separated blah blah blah look
if anybody knows about leveling highly
populated major urban areas
it's the Zach attack baby we get some
decent destruction here but again much
too short and where's the Ground Zero
makeout sesh whoo we got left here
Boehner and Wang hey Lou let's skip
ahead here oh it's the vehicle Peter
Dinklage I love Game of Thrones can't
wait for Dumbledore to sit on the Iron
Throne this season wait he's a giant ah
he's a giant dwarf oh the irony
I guess he's sad because Thanos killed
all his dwarf friends it's been done
Marvel we gotta make this more personal
let's say he had a family on that rig
maybe parents my mother that's it he's
upset about his mother so much so that
he's angered at the mere mention of her
name
we need a badass name for his mom
something too and he could yell out in
anguish Betty
Jake hey it's Martha why did you say
that
[Music]
who the hell is that the ghost of
Christmas future decent seen here
element but we gonna punch it up a bit
much better also the guy with the red
face is now voiced by Michael Shannon
finally some mindless destruction now
this is what I'm talking about
but it needs a little panache that hits
the spot
hey isn't Thor supposed to show up here
what is he gonna do improv them to death
okay that was that was pretty cool
anyway
Santos explains that his big master plan
is to kill off half of all living beings
in the universe only half really Marvel
you gotta bring your numbers up those
are icky numbers I mean where are the
real stakes from scrotum face here
obviously in my version the whole
universe is on the line yeah no he
doesn't owe you an explanation for why
he's doing it he's a bad guy bad guys do
bad things duh by the way
Santos is now played by Jesse Eisenberg
that is paradoxical and well that was
stupid what does this guy do it at the
movie anyway he's dumb he's trying to be
funny in this serious Schneider is Asian
get rid of him even clips son take a
hike yeah say be you buddy
have fun playing another fat guy in an
NBC comedy so of course good guys win
typical Marvel lame boring vanilla wait
what what's happening
what is this stop stop now that black
panther that movie made a billion
dollars grew to that again
please that again good spider-man he was
just too by the by what is going on
[Music]
that's it it's over
how could you end a movie like that
Marvel you heartless bastards you even
killed Batista have you know so high I
don't know what to do with myself now
that was horrific scarring traumatizing
somebody heroes dead I need to come on
Sam Jackson to one of your next movies
better fix this
oh it's Captain Marvel eh well that
sounds like a nice light-hearted film
with absolutely nothing controversial
about it at all I look forward to the
purity
speaking of which we gotta lighten these
films up I'm gonna go convince DC to put
out something for the kids
yeah something we can all enjoy
something nice something fun but not too
fun I can't believe you did this bar
from now on Zack Snyder changes his ways
no longer will my films be
vomit-inducing during action scenes
mopey angry diverge from what made these
characters work in the first place just
so I can shoehorn in my own weirdly
twisted view on character deconstruction
which will then force me to go overboard
defending them from people will ask
simple questions so I can insult them
while conveying them they obviously know
better than they do and they obviously
didn't get it because they're stupid
dumb and just not on my level man no
from now on my films will be optimistic
and fun and filled with hope from this
day forward
you
[Music]